chers habitants de la 13e
circonscription des connu de chassieu
décines charpieu colombier saugnieu
genas le jeune âge jour mes yeux cuisine
y en sont venus aux murs alors mur et
saint priest
je m'adresse à vous aujourd'hui après
l'élection présidentielle pour vous
profite remets ma candidature aux
élections législatives qui se tiendront
les 12 et 19 juin prochains dans la 13e
circonscription ce territoire plein
d'avenir et riche de singularité qu'il
faut préserver
fort de mon bilan en tant que maire de
saint priest
demanda au cours desquelles j'ai pu
développer des projets importants autour
de l'économie de l'emploi de la sécurité
en m'adressant à toutes les forces vives
de monterrey voir une façon extrêmement
dure mais aussi pour l'éducation la
santé de la culture
aujourd'hui le show portail cap
mission à l'échelle de cette responsable
je bénéficie pour cela le soutien de la
grande majorité des maires et des élus
de notre territoire je bénéficie
également du soutien de laurent wauquiez
président de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes le christophe guilloteau au
président du département du rhône de
paul vidal président de la ccrl ou
encore de notre ancien député philippe
meunier
j'ai l'ambition de me battre pour
redonner la parole au maire et aux
habitants je porterai les dossiers de
notre territoire au parlement comme
celui de la rocade est et de l'a46 pour
lesquelles je me suis mobilisé depuis
15 un combat qui nous concerne tous
puisqu'il en va de la qualité de notre
vie quotidienne
vous pouvez me faire confiance ce
territoire je le connais parfaitement
j'y suis né j'y ai grandi la suppléante
denise d'un terrien et lui dessine très
fortement engagée auprès de sa
population m'accompagne dans cette
action au service de tous mon combat
mon engagement
c'est le vôtre et je tiens la firme est
très fortement la défense du territoire
de la communauté communes de l'est
lyonnais fait partie de mon engagement
et je compte sur vous comme vous pouvez
confession